coming up on 6 45 on your monday more
remember last week we're talking about
the henderson symphony orchestra and
their holiday jukebox concert it was a
huge success and i had the honor of
narrating the snowman so as the
orchestra was playing and i was
narrating the animated movie was
actually playing on the wall behind an
overhead and there was a really talented
soloist check out julia fleischer from
coronado high school
[Music]
he fell in his pocket
and the scarf that father christmas had
given him
was still there
i hope you know the story of the snowman
it's a great children's story where the
kid builds a snowman it comes to life
and they go on some adventures he wasn't
sure if it was a dream or not so much
fun the orchestra really great uh jeff
newman the conductor pointing out though
that we really have to give props to all
of the musicians because they're
volunteers they mostly have day jobs
some are students and they still put in
the time to to make it all shine also
props to the to julia flagshire she told
me the snowman's been a family favorite
there forever and so she was really
pumped about uh singing it on stage and
the entire madrigal choir from coronado
also had a few tunes and they knocked it
out of the park gosh i want to watch
more did you video the whole thing
we'll post some stuff online it was a
lot of fun also thanks to uh julie
williams she's the orchestra director of
operations and the folks from uh the
inspirato campus i'm sorry the pinecrest
academy sloan canyon campus beautiful
auditorium down there yeah so i hope you
get a chance to check it out orchestra
sounded fantastic
i know i was into it i want to see more
awesome tips you guys was a lot of fun